it's been a little while since my last
sadler stories video
and since i've got a little bit of time
in between
the game that we're about to watch
packers game of course
and some video work that i was doing
earlier for classes i thought that i
might
take the occasion to do another saddler
stories video and talk about
getting to see the packers so the
packers if you're not familiar with them
are the green bay packers they are our
local nfl sports team
here in wisconsin there's a lot of
packer backers
all across the united states you can
pretty much go to any major city
and find at least one place where you
could watch the game
and hang out with other people usually
packers bars
because you know it's wisconsin so it's
associated with beer and cheese
and things like that right they call
packers fans cheese heads
and i you know growing up here in
wisconsin um
it was almost de rigueur to be a packers
fan although i do have to mention that
that wasn't necessarily the
case for quite a few of the kids that
that i grew up with because
at the time that i grew up the packers
weren't very good and i'll talk about
that
in just a minute now of course they're
kind of a hot team they have been for a
while we've been fortunate to get to see
you know an actual super bowl that they
they won
and they had a bit of a a tough period a
few years ago but with you know the
replacement of the head coach
and getting some things together they're
now doing quite well again
and i wanted to tell a story about
actually getting to see the packers
play we went to and when i say we
i mean my wife and i we went up to
watch them play against their divisional
rival the bears and i'll talk about you
know
the bears in just a couple minutes
we saw them play at lambeau field and
that was my
very first time ever going up to lambeau
field i've been in green bay for other
things
but i haven't hadn't been to lambeau
field and it is like a whole production
there's not just the stadium but there's
all these places where people are
you know before the game parking and you
know cooking
out and hanging out together and
enjoying themselves then they go into
the game then some people hang around
afterwards and do that and then there's
all these
other venues and there's the you know
the
museum that you can go to and the fan
shop so
we did the whole experience and i'll
tell you about that in a minute
that was last season and we actually got
to see the packers
beat the bears in a very very close game
so
so it was really cool but i i've seen
the packers play
two other times in my life not on tv but
actually in the stadium and that was
down here in milwaukee
a lot of people don't know this but the
packers uh for a while would alternate
their home games between green bay
way up north and milwaukee where
you know much more of the population can
can get to and lives in
and so they would play in what was at
that time brewers stadium
you know we're used to calling it miller
park i think it has a new name
now that nobody calls it by any more
than anyone calls sears tower in chicago
hancock tower right
once you get a certain name you're kind
of stuck with it
so when i was a kid and
i really mean a kid not just like a
college student but like
you know when i was in grade school and
then in high school i got to see the
packers play i remember
my dad taking me and i think they might
have been playing the bears at that time
to milwaukee and it was it was him and
me
and then i think we've gotten tickets
because of
his office or something like that and so
we we went along and you know now that i
think about it i think that my
mom and sister came along too and we did
the whole like tailgating thing of
cooking out beforehand
i remember being at the game we were all
like totally bundled up i couldn't see
too much from where we were because i
was you know like i was in elementary
school
so you know i maybe was nine or ten
i don't think i was any older than that
you know i don't think it was when i was
in middle school and i was 11.
so um you know i i just remember
watching it and trying to like pay
attention to what was going on and my
dad being really excited
to be there and having a good time it
was
cold that's the one thing that i can say
about every packers game i've been to
it was cold to where your toes would
hurt
and you know you had to keep your face
somewhat covered some of the time
but you could watch the game and you
were there in the in the stands with
all these other people and you could
hear the noise and it was it was pretty
cool
and then when i was in high school i had
a friend um
from middle school and his name was
george gutenkonst and his dad
actually had a foundry here in milwaukee
that unfortunately was the wrong
wrong you know decades to be in the
steel business
eventually they they went under but at
the time george and his family were
pretty well off
and i would go over to his house on
weekends quite often and my mom would
send me along with a casserole or a
dessert
so that they you know according to my
mom wouldn't think that we were
freeloaders
and we'd kind of you know joke about it
george's mom was really cool his dad was
pretty cool too
and his dad had packers tickets
through some sort of work thing again as
well you know
and so george said hey do you want to
you want to come with us to this this
packers game
and i think george's older sister heidi
was still
she hadn't graduated because i think she
came along as well and so it was me and
george
and um his dad who was always this kind
of dour
guy but it was kind of cool and then his
his mom who was this very funny lady you
know she always had a quip for
everything
and also a really really cool person and
then his sister who is kind of a drama
uh kid you know and i don't think she
was into sports at all quite frankly and
so they were like do you want to come to
the game with us we've got an extra
ticket i was like
yeah of course so we went and we
tailgated and tailgating of course meant
you get there like
hours before the event and you throw the
football around
and you eat good food that everyone's
brought and you know i'm just kind of
wandering around with george
as a kid then it's time to go into the
the the coliseum and watch the game and
i think that they lost that game if i
remember right it wasn't against the
bears they were playing somebody else
and it was
kind of a close game but the packers you
know the packers that i remember
always to use the expression that people
say managed to
you know drag defeat out of the jaws of
victory they'd be doing great for three
quarters of the game and then
they'd screw it up so
um getting to go and see them at lambeau
field with my wife who
is even more enthusiastic about the
packers because she doesn't have any
divided loyalties or anything
like that that i might be accused of uh
was it was a lot of fun
and we we did the whole thing we got up
there uh the the day before
and went to um you know the fan shop
and got some some gear we got some cold
weather gear as well including some foot
warmers for me
because my circulation isn't isn't too
hot ever since i was in the army and got
frostbit in the army
and it was going to be a cold game and
it's not a covered stadium either
so you know we got all of our garb and
our ponchos and all that
and we went to the museum as well and
you know took some pictures
and got to look at all sorts of really
cool stuff and then we went and had a
great dinner
at one of the local places checked into
our our hotel
stayed the night got up early the next
morning
we did the whole shebang where we you go
in early
and there's tailgate parties that you
can be at outside
but the middle of november is not a
great time to be outside in green day
right
so we opted for the one where you pay a
certain amount and then you're in this
place
that is is another um stadium
and they have like you know drinks and
and and
all sorts of food and so you like you
load up on your food beforehand
and you know get some drinks and make
sure you stay hydrated because because
once you get
in the stadium you really don't want to
get out of your seats to have to go find
a restroom
or you know buy some food or buy some
some
beer because it's going to be way
overpriced and you might miss something
and that's that's no fun right so
then of course we we make the long walk
about i think about a mile or so
from the place where we were to the the
stadium itself we get in there and it's
this
massive edifice right all these people
in green and gold with with a few people
in the bears uh blue and orange and
you're looking around and and one of the
cool things about the packers
as far as fans go that you can say
hospitality is something that's
uh very important in the midwest and
the bears are the biggest rivals of the
packers
because they've both been in the nfl
before the nfl even
was the nfl and they've been playing
games against each other
for now 100 years and this was like the
100 year
anniversary right so it was a packers
versus the bears game
and this was a division rivalry game to
like see who would be on top
in the division and one of the things
that's cool
is that this hospitality so there are
some things where like there's a song
the bears still suck and
you do try to make noise when the bears
are trying to
coordinate their stuff and then you're
quiet when they're they're not
but one of the things that you're not
going to see at packers games is
people from other p fans from other
teams
being abused the way they might be say
in philadelphia
or you know patriots games or stuff like
that right
we were sitting next to a bunch of bears
fans everybody now of course once they
started losing they start getting very
quiet you know but nobody was giving any
any anybody else a hard time they aren't
like pushing matches or
telling people to take off their jerseys
or any of that sort of nonsense
it's you know it's midwestern
hospitality you have rivalry you have
competition
but your your understood is like you're
there to watch
that the teams play i can't say that it
was always
like that but that certainly is part of
it now
and so it was a close game we froze our
butts off i can tell you that you know
you'd have to like every so often
um you know i had my whole face covered
basically
so did my wife with it with a gator and
you'd still be cold i
had my poncho on my feet got got cold
and numb
after a while but you're watching the
game and you're there for that you're
cheering them on after a while you lose
your voice
and but it's it's it's a really fun time
and so that was kind of a luxury for us
you know taking a whole weekend to drive
up there
when it's here in milwaukee which you
know that's in the past
obviously it would have been really easy
to go to we can actually get to brewers
stadium
in less than 10 minutes it would take us
longer to park than it would to get
there
but the packers don't play there anymore
they only play up at lambeau
in some respects living where we do
if we wanted to see the packers play the
bears it would be about as much time for
us to go
down to chicago to soldier field as it
would be to drive
up to green bay to go to lambeau so
once we're out of covid maybe my wife
and i might do that
for some of the away games since the
packers play the bears
in the stadium up at lambeau once a year
and play
down in chicago once a year
and i i mentioned something about
divided loyalty so so here's some more a
bit
about my packers story um i'm both a
packers
and a bears fan which to a lot of
packers fans doesn't make any sense
because you're supposed to you know love
one and hate the other
but you see i come from a adopted family
my mom and dad
uh tony and monique sadler who both grew
up in chicago
my mom grew up in the city itself
on 50th and halstead my dad grew up in
arlington heights which is a suburb
so they grew up as being bears fans
right but then they moved
up here to wisconsin my dad came up here
to go to college he
went to uw wisconsin my mom was going to
depaul at the time
ended up getting married to my dad
dropping out and
so they were in wisconsin for a while
and they became not just badgers fans
but also packers fans
we had these these really cool cups
from the 70s that had like you know the
nfl
team logo on it and i remember that we
had
packers ones and bears ones and my dad
and my mom would watch both the games
now when it came to rooting for packers
and bears
i think they probably sided with the
bears right
for me uh in my hierarchy i saw
if the bears are playing the packers i'm
rooting for the packers against the
bears
but i like to see the bears doing good
so this season actually i'm kind of
happy about what's going on
um as a matter of fact if if you know
they could both play in the super bowl
that would be
would be awesome that's never going to
happen of course because they're in the
same
nfc so i i like both of those teams and
i like i like seeing both of them do
good but my allegiance is really
with the packers i also i should mention
you know
i like the colts because i lived in
indiana for quite a while
and i kind of like kind of like them
when i was a kid i liked the steelers
too
uh no real rivalries because those are
in the afc
and you can say well if you don't hate
the bears who do you hate
who do you reserve your your you know uh
fan whatever we want to call it spite
hatred
you know your aggression towards the
vikings of course the minnesota vikings
the lions the detroit lions uh they're
we don't really worry about them too
much because they don't usually do very
well
if they're if they're hot well then i
root against them as well so
you know now sports fan allegiance
rational
not not really i will mention one other
thing before i bring this to a close
which some of the stuff that i've been
saying to some of you may be totally
indecipherable if you're if you're not
you know familiar with
american football so i mentioned i grew
up in the 70s and the 80s
and because of this i got to learn what
it meant to be
a real fan which means you don't abandon
your team
even though they suck and they don't
just suck once
they just suck after suck after suck
after suck so the packers
in the 1970s and the 1980s they did have
a few
good seasons but for the most part it
was losing
over and over and over again again it's
getting pummeled
and to make it worse the packers won the
first two super bowls
so there was all this sort of like you
know in the bart star
era we're gonna go back to that you know
this is the year we're gonna
we're gonna finally go back to the super
bowl and win it that's what all the old
people would be saying
and we young kids would be like yeah
that sounds awesome
and then we'd watch and they would just
lose after lose after lose and be like
oh man this sucks right
and we'd still root for them and
sometimes this led to rather tense
family situations right
because everybody's drinking and you
know
the team is doing badly and all these
you know projections about how they're
gonna finally start turning it around
and we kids would be like oh you know
let's not poke the bear
over there and you know
there were a lot of packers fans i think
when i was a kid
who quit being packers fans because they
were fair weather fans
instead you know what they wore here
they they rooted for the cowboys because
the cowboys back then were hot
were considered america's team and so
sometimes you would see
more uh blue and silver than you would
green and gold
here in in the wisconsin area it was
really kind of kind of interesting
so any case i you know those of us who
kept the faith we can now
in these years these several decades
that have been doing well
under the farv and rogers eras those are
the quarterbacks
um you know we can we can say well they
won two super bowls in that era they've
been
making a good show it wasn't always like
that
and so you know being a fan involves
supporting your team whether they're
doing well whether they're doing poorly
whether they're making
bad decisions or whether they're making
good decisions whether they're getting
pushed around by the better teams
or whether they're one of the better
teams who is succeeding
so um all that said i'm gonna knock this
off
now and get it get it you know
processing and uploaded before the game
starts
in just a few minutes by the time you're
watching this the game is already over
and win or lose i'm going to be happy
just so long as they played up to their
full potential
you